royal avec nour est monté berges
commissaire aux langues officielles
cette héberge on disait tout à l'heure
tu seras peut-être augmenter depuis
depuis vingt-neuf minutes que vous aviez
reçu pour ce simple événement 200
plaintes cs exacte et ce fait vous avez
les ondes avait reçu jusqu'à des deux
s'en plaint effectivement bon ce qui est
énorme losc est hors du commun n'est ce
pas tout à fait atypique main on reçoit
des patients de l'événement quelques
dizaines de plaintes évidemment le
nombre de plaintes extravagantes aux
dates autres à l'apport à d'autres
événements mais pour un discours c'est
quand même extraordinaire d'un record
absolu presque oui messieurs théberge
raconté mois avant le discours de hier
midi comme d'autres vous aviez vu parce
que le journal de montréal nous l'avait
appris qu' il allait parler juste en
anglais est ce exact vous avez pris
comme démarche d'appeler air canada de
leur écoute et je vous conseille pas de
faire ça donc ils avaient été prévenus
par vous avant n'est ce pas oui hein mon
bureau et
une fois qu'on est endetté au courant de
faits que le discours serait uniquement
en anglais mon but au contact et air
canada pour eux pour
leur faire valoir nos préoccupations
mais évidemment le discours était
prononcé en anglais avec les autos qu'on
voit présentement qu'est-ce qu'on a
répondu aux gens chez vous qui ont
appelé au canada est ce qu'on a dit
merci au revoir
qu est ce qu on a dit
ce qu'on essentiellement ce qu'on le dit
c'est que c'est un discours à la chambre
de commerce c'était discours où elle a
comme l'aider à faire donc je n'étais
pas c'étaient ceux des dépôts
financièrement comme une communication
avec le public tel que défini par la loi
ce les danses d'officiel donc
évidemment pour plusieurs citoyens
citoyennes
ce discours a été perçu est vu comme une
communication avec le public explique le
nombre important de plaintes qu'on a
reçues souhaitait bergère canada est un
sujet oh la la loi sur les langues
officielles dans ce pays est ce que le
gras grands patrons devraient être
bilingue selon vous et bien à mon avis
étant donné la valeur de symbole dispo
tour d'air canada je pense que de hauts
dirigeants aux deux premiers dirigeants
de ce genre d'entreprise comme toutes
les instances fédérales de verre à mon
avis être bilingue prête à mesure de
communiquer quand les deux langues
officielles non seulement aux employés
aux autres intervenants mais à la
population canadienne par tout
ça faisait longtemps qu'on n'avait pas
vu un tel resserre qu'une de telles
réactions et beaucoup de gens souligner
qu'air canada est un mauvais élève quant
aux langues officielles qu'est ce que
vous en dites et bien année après année
on reçoit un nombre de plaintes
vis-à-vis air canada vis-à-vis de cette
la qualité des services surtout en
français soit dans les habits ion soin
d'aller dans les aéroports et ça perdure
depuis plusieurs années - de montpezat
soeur avait émis un rapport spécial au
gouvernement et le gouvernement n'a pas
agi on nous laisse entendre lors de la
modernisation de la loire côté pour se
pencher là dessus donc on attend
toujours à savoir quelles seront les
prochaines étapes de cette modernisation
est vous découragez monsieur théberge en
terminant deux fois face à l'attitude
d'un canada
je pense que je suis souvent un
commissaire est souvent préoccupé et
déçu donc j'ai l'impression que quand on
recommence souvent que l'on fait des
recommandations
ont fait un nombre incroyable de
recommandation c'est souvent à refaire
donc sonné à l'anti au point que à mon
avis c'est systémique et on doit trouver
une approche beaucoup plus globale pour
essayer de traiter de cette situation le
commissaire n'a pas les pouvoirs pour le
faire ils allaient pouvoir de
recommandation donc à ce moment ici on
répète souvent les limites humaines j'ai
avec les mêmes résultats
en conclusion est ce que la nouvelle loi
qui avait déposé madame joly qui sera
redéposer est ce que la nouvelle loi va
donner plus de mordant à au gouvernement
pour faire quelque chose et bien d'un un
tas de projets de loi qui
malheureusement mort au feuilleton
effectivement on accordait aux
commissaires des nouveaux pouvoirs en
matière d'autres exploits d'émettre des
ordonnances donc une gradation de
pouvoir qui n'existe pas mais bon il ya
un peu plus de moyens raymond théberge
merci de nous avoir parlé commissaire
aux langues officielles qui en appelait
les bras avec les dossiers d'air canada
merci nous en avoir parlé en direct et
je veux par la pire tuerie qui connaît
bien évidemment la communauté anglophone
de montréal ancien maire de westmount
entre autres pendant 5 madame monsieur
bonsoir monsieur
qu'est ce que vous avez vu comme
réaction vous j'ai entendu d'autres
anglophones qui ont dit vraiment là il
il n'aura pas service on donne à usage
de la communauté de la fan un peu
arriérés
je pense ils ont ainsi gentil moi je
suis un peu plus
sidéré passer une valeur lorsqu'il m'a
même réaction si tr 7 e
s ou sont toujours en 1960 ici au très
ambitieuse je trouve c'est vraiment
impensable
que le dj de l'orgasme anglade autre
tournée au canada ils me rendent
capables de se déterminer en france
disent tous sont
acceptables et surtout allophones
monsieur je suis gêné et surtout
maintenant on va
le projet de loi
96 où on veut devenir la communauté
anglophone veut avoir les aussi
doucement mais maintenant en faire là
qui sort d'un homme aussi notre niche
tout ce que
vous avez vu la des relents des années
60 mais je crains que j'avais vu la wii
que les jets d'affaires de montréal le
parler en anglais à leurs employés ne
s'abaissait pas apprendre le français je
suis heureux ici au québec 69 et c'était
comme ça que tu pas les dirigeants des
pensées des ministres à sion à paris pas
nos français et moi et je parlais pas
français non plus mais au moins j'ai
fait des trucs à apprendre et je trouve
que même si mon français pas attaquable
il faut dire aussi vous sera pas besoin
de français impeccable
on a besoin de face il faut quand même
humilité et respectés ne me verrez des
gens d'ici ok
il ya la cobac community groups network
de marlene jennings quelqu'un qui
représente donc la communauté anglophone
en troll qui a dit ça nous fait un tort
un incroyable et puis même les excuses
n'arriveront pas faire disparaître le
tort que sa cause est à la communauté
anglophone on ça donne une image de nous
dépasser donc vous êtes d'accord alors à
ce moment ci plus il selon vous rester
en poste
il faut qu'ils se tuent et le jugement
de son côté réuni situation lien à 2 12
personnes qui oppose le procès d'une
station et toi aussi d'user sont des
gens qui habitent québec et je à mon
avis c'est pas juste la faute de
monsieur aussi que c'est une station qui
ignorer les réalités
tube elle oublie aussi que très tard il
faut pas oublier
ccvg des gens ni francfort à l'extérieur
du québec il faut que même
si vous avez évoqué mais se traîne en
terminant que vous avez vous et c'est
connu la communauté anglophone voudrait
voir des changements projet de loi sur
la peau qui échangent la loi 101 de
monsieur je n'ai barrette est ce que
vous vous êtes dit eh ben ça y est on
pourra jamais plaidé des changements ça
va juste être une loi peut être à vos
yeux plus dur qui va arriver mais c'est
justement ma faim
parce que il y as une définition de
allophones et historique et je suis un
anglais haché mais je ne me considère
pas
anglophone est habile
étant donné des gages en est ici dont
ils vivent et édition de koh phi peuvent
recevoir les services en anglais et ne
sommes que les français les francophones
sont assez généreux c'est peut-être
faire un assouplissement l'attend mais
excellent qui la vident hier soir à
eygalières la somme qui sera beaucoup
plus difficile de convaincre monsieur
legault le fait a dit ceci pousse mon
projet de loi projet de loi 96 ancien
maire de west point merci beaucoup nous
avons parlé en direct s'est apprécié
votre colère c'est très très clair merci
a bientot au revoir